[Music]
[Applause]
carson palmer former nfl quarterback of
course heisman trophy winner his weekly
appearance brought to you by level
select cbd how'd the bengals lose this
game
well it was just a magnificent game for
for all of us fans for the cincinnati
fans um to come in as an underdog and
somebody that you know people didn't
really give a shot or give a chance to
they they hung in there they had the
lead
uh this team is here to stay you know
they have a great offseason ahead of
them with 60 million dollars suspended
free agency uh some players they're
probably going to retain and they can
make a big splash in this free agency
they've got to shore up that offensive
line there's a bunch of vets there's a
bunch of guys
uh tara and armstead uh the new orleans
saints is a great tackle brandon sherf
is a great guard of the washington
commanders there's a bunch of guys out
there to go and get and this is an
opportunity to to really build that you
know they have a four or five year
window here they got joe joe burrows on
a rookie deal he's probably going to
resign
a massive contract in 2024 so they can
they can attack free agency right now
and shore up that offensive line give
him some help give him some support and
still be be prepared for his contract
that's coming up in a couple years
okay how much confidence do you have in
the bengals that they will do right by
joe burrow
not a lot i mean i just look at history
and and history says
you know they're they're happy with
where they're at and they're going to
sit pat but again the way things are
structured right now with the salary cap
and free agency they can go and be super
aggressive they can i mean von miller is
a free agent they could use another pass
rusher a third down specialist um you
know chandler jones is out there another
veteran great defensive and they can go
out
and and attack free agency because what
they can do with joe's contract is they
can sign him in 2024 to a long-term deal
and back load a ton of the money so that
they still have room in 2024 for the
vets they can sign right now in 2022.
well i think it's tougher for the
bengals to try to come back than the
rams because if i look at the two
favorites overall favorites it'll be the
chiefs and the buffalo bills so two afc
teams whereas the nfc if aaron rodgers
leaves tom brady's out of there and
maybe that bodes well russell wilson
could be out of the nfc as well that
bodes well for the rams coming back even
though you got odell beckham with his
injury and a free agent von miller free
agent you lose your offensive
coordinator kevin o'connor who takes the
vikings job but you still have stafford
at a bargain he's i think 23 million
dollars
uh cooper cup is
you know whatever 16 million dollars so
seems like the rams they'll have to
replace whitworth i think uh
he's going to announce his retirement
but you still have jaylen ramsey i mean
you still have some impact players but
then you also have the aaron donald
situation like rodney harrison threw
that out and i went wait a minute this
is the guy who's making nine million
dollars a year it felt like it was a
little bit more of a i think i need to
be up around 18 to 20 million dollars
here guys uh or i just might retire what
do you make of what donald said you know
to rodney
yeah i mean he's he's definitely
positioning himself for a for a pay
increase he's the fifth or sixth highest
paid defensive player in the league
there's no doubt he should be if not the
the highest paid defensive player in all
the league top two top three so
we'll probably see that get fixed this
off season but back to the afc i mean
the nfc is right you're right with all
those vets out of the league the nfc is
right but again in the afc the bengals
beat the chiefs twice yeah so i know the
chiefs are a contender i don't
necessarily like how the bengals match
up with the bills on paper
but i would have said the same thing
about how the bengals match up with the
chiefs on paper and they beat them at
home and then they beat them at their
home so
they've won one on both sides and and i
think the bengals are going to be here
to stay
how painful was it for you to watch
the ending last night
you know i i'm so happy for stafford it
wasn't that painful i really wanted i
really wanted to see a victory played in
downtown cincinnati would have been
amazing i think we will i mean joe
burrow is that good you know jamar chase
is that good if they can keep these guys
together figure out a way to resign t
higgins keep you know joe mixon happy
they've got the big three
with with really a fourth and t higgins
so um the the infrastructure's there
they've got to address the offensive
line the defensive line i mean how
stingy was that defensive line of the
bengals last night it's like every time
they handed the ball off to the rams
running back he ran into a brick wall so
i mean the pieces are there they've got
the right formula they've got the right
guys again they've got a rookie contract
at quarterback that they that's playing
with house money right there when you're
when you're paying your your starting
quarterback who's probably the best
player on the field a rookie minimum
deal that that is playing with house
money so they they've got the the right
infrastructure the right pieces around
it they just got to attack this
offseason
put us in stafford shoes of you know
your receiver is going to be double team
that final drive with cooper cup but can
you still throw somebody open when
they're going to be double covered
obviously you can i mean cooper cups you
know you think back to the greatest
receivers in history and you think of
larry fitzgerald and megatron and the
size and the bulk or the speed of some
of these guys and it's like you don't
quite trust that cooper cup is that good
but when you see sean mcvay hand him the
ball as a running back on the play of
the game on fourth and one and just know
that he's got two guys he's got to beat
and and trust that he's going to beat
him the guy is that good it's not flashy
it's not sexy it doesn't blow you away
like some of the stuff jamar chase does
some of the catches that odell beckham
jr has made over his career it's not
that flash he's just so consistent and
so dominant that when the game's on the
line stafford's been around long enough
he's been in those drives many a times
he knows that when you're down whether
it's the super bowl or regular season
game you've got to get the ball in your
best
you got to give it to your best player
without a doubt no matter what sometimes
he may be triple covered he can still
find a way to get open he was getting
open against double coverage and that's
why he's so special
okay you get down on the goal line and
you see eli apple's single covering
cooper cup i mean come on
i mean that's
how do you get to the point where you
have single coverage on cooper cup at
the goal line
well especially the way that the
defensive front for the bengals was
stopping the run with four-man pressures
i mean their their four defensive
linemen owned the line of scrimmage they
owned the rams offensive line so they
didn't need to load the box and bring
nine guys into the box to stop the run
they were doing it with four guys all
game
but again if cincy can go after you know
patrick peterson's a free agent xavier
rhodes is a free agent there's some guys
hopefully they get trey wayne's back in
the starting lineup and he can be the
player that the bengals anticipated him
being when they gave him that contract
there's just a couple pieces away where
you get patrick peterson out there on
cooper cup that's a pretty good matchup
so there's a couple pieces away and they
just didn't need to leave eli apple
one-on-one with triple crown winner
that turf at the stadium with what
happened odell beckham jr is that
turf related or obj related
it sure didn't look turf related i mean
it's hard to say that right now the day
after the game that's just one of those
acls i hope it's not torn i hope it's
just
um maybe a bone on bone collision that
he felt in there
but it did not look like it was the turf
that turf's only a handful of years old
i'm sure it's holding up pretty good
that looked like unfortunately i've been
there that looked like a knee that was
reconstructed surgically a couple years
ago and then maybe gave out it happened
to me it happens pretty easily and when
it does happen it's very rarely a
collision or a traumatic injury where
somebody is crashing into you a lot of
times when you see that it's just a guy
planting or running or jumping and that
looked to be what it was with obj
yesterday well he took first of all the
pass was behind him a little bit and he
took his eye off the ball because it was
almost as if he had caught it now he was
looking to see i mean he was looking to
get up a field quicker than he should
have and it just felt like it was just
an awkward moment there
those are the ones unfortunately i hate
to say it i'm knocking on wood
unfortunately those are the ones that
that typically are an acl expiring
snapping breaking tearing whatever it
was
um you hope i mean he's a free agent as
well i believe so yeah you hope it's not
completely torn and he has to start over
again and go through the whole rehab
process hopefully it's a little bit of a
tear and they can fix it or just clean
it up and and he'll be ready once once
training camp opens in august and it
felt like he was on his way to if they
were winning he was going to be in the
mvp conversation last night he just felt
like he got that touchdown had a couple
of big plays there and then all of a
sudden had that injury we've talked
about aaron donald before and just how
great he is but
you know going up the middle against a
quarterback
and a lot of quarterbacks have said on
this show you know they worry about the
guy who's coming right at him not
necessarily the guy on the edge
what is it about aaron donald you you
sort of know what you're getting
you just can't stop it so
what role do you play in trying to help
your team uh as a quarterback
well you got to run the ball and and
they tried to run the ball and they did
a good job i mean joe mixon had a
phenomenal game but at the end of the
day there is no recipe for aaron donald
i i've seen great ones go up against him
and and double team him and he is that
much quicker that much more powerful and
what you don't realize about aaron is
how short he is and all that does is
people want to say i want the six five
320 pound guy but i don't i want the 511
the guy that can get underneath your
pads
most offensive linemen are a little bit
stiffer than defensive lineman and don't
have that ability to get low and sink
their hips well aaron doesn't have to
sink his hips he comes off the ball with
so much power and leverage that i don't
care if you got pro bowlers up front it
really doesn't matter if your double
team if you're slide protecting and
trying to wash him down he finds a way
and they do such a good job by putting
him every once in a while on the same
side of the field with with ron miller
putting him outside and looping him and
running all kinds of games where he's
not just bull rushing up field he's
running around the d the offensive
tackle and getting an edge he's just
that good he's that dominant and again i
don't think we see him retiring i think
he's posturing for a new contract which
looks well deserved we had tony baselli
on he's going to the hall of fame and he
said you know i hated playing against
those shorter guys they had leverage on
me and you know and biselli's six seven
and he said you know that
the guy who's
six feet 511 those are the guys i
brought up john randall like these guys
that are just they here they come
they're not tall but they they just have
that leverage
yeah i mean warren sapp was the same
warren sapp wasn't 6'5 340. he played
with great leverage he played with great
power gino atkins a great bengal
defensive tackle that didn't get the
credit he deserved he was a phenomenal
phenomenal player a lot he was really
built very similar to aaron donald maybe
he didn't have quite the same power but
the same quickness he was six foot maybe
standing on a book i mean maybe he was
six one but probably below six foot but
that leverage uh it doesn't matter how
long your tackle your your arms are at
tackle or guard or center if you can get
underneath an offensive lineman's
shoulder pads and aaron does it with one
arm so i mean you see him grabbing guys
with one arm putting in somebody's chest
and just deepening him out of the way so
there's just a rare combination of speed
and power that aaron has that maybe we
haven't seen since john randall
did you meet anybody interesting in los
angeles
um
i didn't meet anybody out of the
ordinary but i was in and out as quick
as possible it was an honor to finally
come and sit in your studio your
makeshift studio that was great there
but that traffic and and just the chaos
of the super bowl i could not i was
literally driving home thinking
i can't believe i lived here for four
years in college and i'm so glad i'm out
right now because i just i was going 12
miles at one point and it took me an
hour and 45 minutes to move 12 miles in
the car
i went from marina del rey to downtown
it took me 90 minutes and it's 12
12 and a half miles
like i
i could gone to law school i think if if
i commuted in los angeles i probably
could get a law degree in a you know
maybe a year's time of just sitting in
traffic
yeah what's all this talk about work
from home nobody's working from home
everybody's on the damn highways and
freeways and you know i expected to you
know what was crazy though is i did do a
trip in the middle of uh
in the middle of
the quarantine the 14 day lockdown and i
drove from san diego to santa barbara
and i was going 80 miles an hour up the
405 through century city
past griffis observatory around you know
you know on highways and on parts of
freeways that i'd never i've never gone
faster than 10 miles an hour and there
was nobody on the roads it was a really
eerie ghost town feel we uh we had coach
oh on
did he did he recruit you
he didn't recruit me but he was he was
the defensive line coach at usc when i
was there and i was scared the death of
a guy
all he talked about was sacking me all
he talked about was i you know it'd be
march and we're you know
in the weight room working out and all
of a sudden i'd hear this noise behind
me and he come up boy
i'm gonna come and get you boy and i
turn around oh
dripping sweat just got off the bench
press talking about sacking me so that
that guy scared the hell out of me he
said that he would bring recruits down
to manhattan beach
and then he would say
see that house that's kobe's see that
house that's denzel it goes i didn't
know if it was their houses but i told
that to the recruits
like no chance no chance the stories i
want from the stories i want from eddio
was what was going on at lsu
how did he get how are some of those
recruiting situations how did he get
some of the talent down there because
nobody bats an eye on what's going on in
baton rouge everybody in baton rouge is
an lsu fan you don't have to be as
worried about all the little tidbits of
the recruiting laws so i want to know
some of those lsu stories well we
brought up texas a m i go you know
jimbo fisher's all upset because his you
know guys aren't getting the credit for
recruiting all these kids and he started
laughing because you know i said that's
oil money there you know i mean come on
and now it's it's above board
you're live i can give you whatever i
want you like on the open market what do
you think you'd be worth coming out of
high school
i don't even know what it is right now i
i at least a million
yeah who knows at least a million but
he's the hands down the best recruiting
coordinator the best recruiter i've been
around he's relentless he's always
watching film he would pull up things on
his laptop
of some grainy video he had of some kid
in south florida and i'm like coach you
can't even see this kid and he's like i
know but you know he had all the stats
all the numbers he knew the mom and dad
are like he was relentless in his
pursuit in recruiting it was it was
truly amazing
but he told us a story he was trying to
recruit adrian peterson to usc
and adrian's dad was in prison is in
prison in oklahoma he tried to get him
transferred to
an a los angeles prison
so he could watch his son play football
that was you know that's why adrian
stayed at oklahoma
and and you know coach ogo's
i was competing gotta compete that's all
i was trying to do compete i can't
imagine you go back to school and you go
um hey i got adrian peterson but his
dad's got to be transferred to la county
jail
oh the strings that had to be pulled
i'll tell you what happened with that
probably though is adrian peterson's dad
was like you want me you're going to
transfer me to la county
no thank you i'll stay here things are a
little more cushy maybe in oklahoma than
l.a county prison
uh it was great seeing you you and your
son and uh thanks again buddy
thanks dan that's carson palmer his
weekly appearance brought to you by
level select cbd looking for next level
relief visit levelselectcbd.com